so onions
potatoes
for seven years jane has been taking
excess supermarket food and delivering
it to vulnerable people but a few weeks
ago she had a special delivery of her
own completely astonished i had to keep
looking that it was actually meant for
me
the honor of an obe last year the
project supplied 30 million meals to
disadvantaged families and continues to
play a part in solving the cost of
living crisis the honor is for the whole
organization as much as it is for me i
feel and it doesn't make any difference
in how much energy i or anybody else is
going to put into this amazing wonderful
organization
eleven-year-old twins eleanor and ruben
are the youngest award recipients
through running challenges they've
raised over 50 000 pounds for the nhs
but they didn't immediately know what
the british empire medal was i think
it's incredible well when
when i first found out i didn't i didn't
realize how i am how um how amazing it
was my dad then talked me for a bit and
then i realized him how and
how amazing and cool it was
it makes us feel really proud and
honorable and we're really privileged to
be here and awarded this amazing award
a privilege is also how sir quentin
blake described his honor the
illustrator of the role dull books has
been given a cbe initials reserved for
outstanding service former england
footballer rio ferdinand receives an obe
for his sporting achievements and
charity work and there's a cbe for actor
damian lewis for his role as an active
campaigner
the horrors of covert 19 may be behind
us but the heroes of the pandemic are
still emerging like 22 year old alex
griffiths a healthcare worker who
volunteered to sit with people in
hospital as they died because their
families weren't allowed inside one
patient wanted
to have her rosary beads so every time
we'd go in um and just reposition her
and make sure she was all okay and
everything it was just making sure she'd
we'd given her her rosary beads back at
the end
because that is what brought her comfort
for leading much of the covert 19
response professor stephen powis
receives a knighthood for services to
the nhs
joining him the former first minister of
northern ireland arlene foster as she
becomes a dame i do acknowledge
absolutely the fact that it's about
representation and the fact that i
represented for man on south tyrone for
18 years and the fact that i was the
first female first minister in northern
ireland so i think it's a
it's actually to honor all of those
things as well but for me personally
it's a huge thrill
securing a place on the queen's birthday
honours list is always special but
getting one in her platinum year brings
an extra sparkle ashna harinag sky news